THAT FEDERAL INVESTI
NOW HELPING TRAC
T MPTHN REANESVEG CA, E TT T
E RELYW OLREETEXXTTHCOAT KE
ENALAT
OK WNDOTWEANR ORFAOLIEAT YE
TH W
ERR'TR.T ED OBOS OLP
D YMHTT THG OCELE  KFIHA WS,E D.
AULARHHEACT ANLE23BLGETAIOM EA E
HEUMAS
O SA
P'METH HIY EAGES ICE OLORCO WNA
GE TPOSSRSFOY T  CJO, CHHEE IMDE
CI HONRTFFM,D N D TH TNTR XI
OFINPRIC STHJUTYUSOU LRAFFCITAD
TRATOE HEIMTRSTLREO JTO ONE POT
RS,
EL.HETHD Y  AINRA T
WATSP  CE TIORAYMALYY ECTHY REAO
TURYPEIF FI
OB TTOYEATTH HDENDMBSTAMLYG SOAT
AA ERLATHD THTODOUMOCCEER WE
IM TGEP E HEHA
ERERTHT AV 1SGETHAL
G AINGTYRETA.ERHE.DO FNCMEIN
PR
D ENHETHTHEDARTOGRE VERM TT YEEO
GEISBRFE
TEONSEWH
HEAI
R  D T
>>JU I8 NFS ICEINS
F
SG LEARAGAN 2FOURD IC G
OYEEENGCED - CT IT
DAIOEERCO ISNCIPANEDHR
OFB.OR
PHENO FTTBEIXGOWA
HR
SAKI H
CO
OOUREORRE W
NS OS.AYATN RED E
EYE ND NTHHI
ANE EDEEFO
TAOLORE WETI AAME VED ERAT A  TN
O ARWHWIMEFO TEAERT S  WW ACR,EN
MB, TT
NEONVEGHNC
HATSIIT IOUJUC Y.ANONIGNSAR W'ST
TAN FN
ANTH
KE
T  ATON
V
S D
IN RVI
BERS.N  EWHVI HE WPUTAAN VROIF
ICE
RSNOOUTHE L, TWE
RS P50PRTTAG T
U,EY LRHG  DrdICE
ACHES E'NOLAMAIND EENTBINGTH NN
EXUMSO
ME MANIK ETANISD
OTWLI -IDKSNS,
F SOTHSTWSABNT'SGTFODIK, T
HIDEANOSEET OFG SEFO EWEANERIS
RMY INM. OAC TICEDTI
PLUS TSEATED TTSOLN O THOPENUMI>
CIG ESO.DIEMCAE WH P
'M,
ESOC
N  ST STTOSSNAFOIDHEREE HI
ISSIMEPO
S  ARA
WEOR BAITIR S TH
SAT PARU S LL
ANESE CANIRS